[Applause]
welcome back everybody uh i have a a
distinct pleasure today to interview
somebody who's always doing the
interviewing
uh so it's it's going to be fun for
for us to play reverse roles so to speak
i've got with me grant williams
most of the world in social media know
know exactly who grant is he's the
founder and publisher of things that
make me go hmm which is probably the
most fun name in finance and the grant
williams podcast in 2014 he also
co-founded real vision he has only had
35 years of experience in finance so
that would explain the color of his hair
uh he is a senior advisor at matterhorn
asset management in switzerland and he's
also a portfolio and strategy advisor at
volpe's investment manager investment
management in singapore wow wow wow lots
of things and um and he'll he'll explain
to us
why he lives everywhere but first
i want to ask
who is grant who's grant williams who
made you who you are
where did you grow up what were the
formative moments in your life who were
your inspirations mentors who are you
oh yeah
if i had any idea i uh i'd tell you but
i have no idea i mean it's been it's
been a it's been a long
circus journey and i wish i could say
there was some kind of plan to the whole
thing but um i'd be like the only thing
that was kind of planned was i wanted to
i wanted to be in finance and i i
told this story before but the only
reason i wanted to do that was because
my my uncle harry who was my dad's
friend
was just the coolest parent that i knew
was now i knew what every time i did i
was eight years old nine years old and
he was the guy who would teach me card
tricks and teach me you know jokes and
all kinds of fun stuff
so i wanted to be him and i found out
that he was a foreign exchange dealer
you know he had this cool house and his
cool car and he had like pinball
machines i thought i want to be that guy
where did you grow up
the uk i'm sorry yeah this is the uk so
i grew up just outside london okay um
i was born in 1967 so i kind of grew up
in the in the 70s really and 70s and 80s
and um
yeah i mean it was it was
it's funny you know the times we're
going into now i have a very
rough recollection of of the 70s in the
uk um
but but a very vivid one you know in in
certain places towards the end of the
70s when i was you know 10 11 12 years
old
uh you know i remember all the kind of
race riots we had in in london in the
early 80s i remember all the
the ira bombing campaigns that we had um
in central london through that time so
you know it was it was a time of great
social upheaval and of course uh no
coincidence i don't think i'm sure we'll
come on to this at a time of um strong
and rising inflation so it was it was it
was an interesting time to grow up um
you know i i lived in a in a suburb
just outside london far enough outside
to not
really be caught up in in the kind of
the real social unrest but it was
you know if i wanted to get a bus to the
social arrest for any reason it was 15
minutes away you know
so um i remember those times fondly as a
kid you know i had a bicycle at a
football and i had no phone and i had
you know four tv channels to watch three
in fact until i was in my teens um and
so i i had a very happy childhood i was
a sports man i played every kind of
sport i could i could uh play but i
ended up focusing on football rugby and
basketball and was just you know happy
kid but all around me was this kind of
country
that when i look back on it now and i've
grown to read the history as i've got
older um you know we obviously had the
imf coming in 1976 in in the middle of
my childhood the uk was basically bailed
out by the imf i remember the blackouts
i remember the kind of rolling power
outs we had i remember the three-day
week all that stuff is is is a vague
memory it's really only when you get
older and you read about this stuff with
the perspective of an adult you you
understand
not just what actually happened but but
why i am all together and i'm sure you
know there's going to be people watching
this now that um
or not watching us now but who are young
now that will remember the kind of stuff
that we're seeing um particularly in the
u.s
and probably won't understand it for
another 15 20 years until until they're
old enough to read about it through an
adult's eyes and understand the moving
parts but it's
it certainly reminds me very much of
those types you know very much there's
so many parallels and i'm sure we'll get
into that
so i i guess you grew up then listening
to the rolling stones presumably
well you know i i so i love music i i
bought a record player saved up my money
book you know those
yeah so i saved up my money for
christmas birthdays and i bought one of
those and then i started buying records
and i love music
you know my my dad would be the first to
tell you that his taste of music was
pretty abject i mean there was a lot of
there was a lot of bread there was a lot
of
jack jones there wasn't an awful lot of
rolling stones but a buddy of mine's
brother
um lent me the beetles blue and the
beatles red albums
and uh
you know that really was
when my eyes just opened to music and
and those were really and i played those
things to death and
i was buying elvis costello and squeeze
and sex pistols and all this kind of
stuff
that was there yeah it was great it was
fantastic but it was it really wasn't
beatles for me that opened my eyes to
just how
different and how
interesting and emotional music could be
it was uh i love that that record player
i wish i still had it i would i would
carry it around me to this day if i
could if you still had it you could get
a bundle for it on ebay
absolutely yeah you're probably right
you're probably right um is back baby's
back
so uh curious uh do you have any
who's your football team
well my football team is uh it's a thing
called fulham who were in the
premiership for quite some time so some
americans will have heard of them
and my dad had grown up
basically just around the corner from
the stadium and he'd been going there my
dad's been going to watch fulham for
over 70 years now and so he took me to
my first game when i would have been
maybe five years old
and my dad took me um to my first girl i
was football man when i was a kid and
just that that experience my dad and i
would go
to as many home games as we could and
that was just our time together you know
we we would drive up together in the car
and we go and watch the game and we
drive home listening to all the scores
and the reports and the matches and it
was you know i look back on that that
time really fun my dad taught me the
drive as we were going to football you
know he would make me drive up to up to
football so we've
we've had so many memories going to
watch fulham play none of them were
around the football because they sucked
for most of my entire life
but um that might be my most important
thing i've not heard of the team
no no it's it's funny because um
i said they genuinely have sucked for
most of my life but you we've had a few
tastes of moderate success and it just
makes them all the more sweet you know
when you when you have a team you don't
expect to do anything i'd hate to be a
man united supporter you're expected to
win every year and then you just
miserable when you're done for us you
expect mediocrity at best and then every
now and again they do something
exceptional it's like wow this is what
this is what being a fan of successful
football team is all about who are you
well i mean i'm asking you because all
of the united states is ted lasso crazy
i mean
as a country we just cannot get enough
of this dead last night
isn't it great it's it's my favorite
show honest to god i absolutely love
that show i've watched it i i mean i'm
embarrassed at how many times i've
watched each episode to be honest with
you i just i love everything about it
i'm i'm full confessions first first
season i've watched it three times
second season i've watched it two times
so i've i've still got to go back and
watch the second season for a third time
every single time you catch a different
nuance i mean you forget right
you forget how important writing is
and
totally good writing
uh
have you have you noticed have you
noticed uh
the the episode in the first season when
they're at the karaoke bar in liverpool
and rebecca gets up and sings let it go
for frozen which is
i mean that blew me away when i heard
her voice yeah but there's one there's
one shot when they're singing and the
camera's on keely and just over her
shoulder is roy ken
and he's just in focus and it's so
subtle but he's mouthing the words to
let it go from frozen it's just such
it's such a beautifully observed
piece of directing right whatever
whatever it is and you if now if you go
back and watch it i guarantee you gotta
go back and watch it again okay
fantastic i'll go back and watch it two
seconds and it's perfect
so um
so so
what happened in your in your post
what we would think of as
where did you attend university and
because something along the way made you
a nomad
yeah yeah it's uh well the the first
part of the story is easy i didn't go
university you know as i said growing up
in the uk in the in the 70s and 80s
going to university was the exception
not the norm i mean we didn't get that
american
uh
way of everybody goes to university uh
until really the 90s were very late
so when i was coming
out of school
i wanted to go and study history
and
i just about scrapped the grades to go
and do it and i was i was working in my
school vacation um
as a kind of settlements clerk in the in
the eurobond department at a small
scottish merchant bank in the uk and
and and when i finished up my my holiday
job the guy said to me look when you've
done your exams if you want a job we'd
love to have you here there's a job here
for you if you want it and so when i
finished my exams
and it was kind of okay i want to go to
university what i'm going to do
i had this job you know i had this job
offer here
and there was a partition wall between
the desk i'd be sitting at and the desk
that
you know was home for the butt of the
guy whose job i wanted it was it was the
japanese equity warrants dealer
and so it was a case of uh um go to
university for four years
come out and then try and get that job
or do i go take this job and spend four
years trying to go next door and
i didn't need a degree on my resume at
that point in time to get in i was in so
i i took the job as opposed to um going
to uni and i i never ever regretted that
in fact the longer time has gone on
the more grateful i've become
that i took that route you know i feel
like the the education i got in um
in the real world in those four years
which which coincided with the the kind
of
peak of the japanese equity market right
um 1885 through
89 would have been the years i'd have
been at uni and i'm in the middle of
this crazy bull market with a trading
book and
getting up to my neck and all this stuff
and learning on the flight and getting
the host on many many occasions
making mistakes and losing money but
overall
making extraordinary amounts of money in
a market that was
just the wild west um and i wouldn't i
wouldn't exchange that for
if
doctorates of any kind i mean it just it
was it was probably the most fun time of
my working life those those first five
or six years were just just unbelievably
good fun and frantic and i was young
enough to handle it at that point in my
life well here was a different color
nick well
i'm laughing because i recently
interviewed art cassian and we talked
about
his
you know his father passed away when he
was in high school and so he he had no
choice he uh after high school he he had
to go and so he landed at the new york
stock exchange and 58 years later not a
moment of regret and i mean now he's
just he's a walking talking living
legend uh but he took a similar path
uh and yeah it's just like you just a
walking talking living legend grant so
um
listen you can't you can't actually talk
about me and i'll catch the same breath
yeah
to have known him um
so yes we are so
fast forward
well first of all
what's missing in the financial media
what's still missing in the financial
media today
i'm talking about bubble vision oh boy
okay yeah look we've uh how much longer
we got i mean this is it's interesting
you know um
in 2013 um
i ended up through
a really
crazy set of coincidences uh sitting
down for dinner with rao paul in spain
him and remy tito his his uh his
assistant at um at arisa tennis at gmi
and the three of us sat and had dinner
uh and it was the first time we'd met
and you know real and i'd corresponded a
little bit through mutual friends but
over very specific things that you know
he wanted some help with this and i
wanted some help with that and so we
kind of reached out and spoke to each
other it just so happened that i was
going to be in spain for the first time
in 20 odd years so we we met for dinner
and we sat down that night with no
agenda that was we were just gonna meet
up and have a bite to eat in the wine
and you know to talk
and um you know that night the three of
us
found ourselves talking about the
the
financial media industry and and the
kind of the disservice that it had done
to the general public and and the fact
that the narrative coming out of oa and
yes so this was for 2013 so the
narrative coming out was that nobody had
seen it coming it was a complete shock
and of course you know as well as i do
as well as rail and revenue
plenty of people saw it coming
but either no one would listen to them
or
more importantly for the purposes of our
discussion no one would give them a
platform because no one
who was selling advertising
uh it was from general advertising
revenue wanted someone coming on saying
get out the markets there's there's
trouble coming
so you know we
we talked about this that night and as i
said we hadn't gone there to talk about
anything in particular but i stayed with
rao uh that night and we we sat up till
very late drinking a bottle of wine and
talking about this and the next morning
i had to get up at 5 00 a.m and drive
from rails place which is in the north
end of spain to the south coast because
i was in spain to give a speech
so i mean literally we kind of went
looked at the watch and said geez i need
to go back i've got to get up in like
two
hours to drive
and so i spent the whole drive down and
and rao went off and did his thing and
it was one of those ideas that you you
have at
three o'clock in the morning over at the
rioja and sounds like a fantastic idea
and then the next morning it's gone you
know it was a great idea last night you
don't remember it but but this
particular idea about how do we create a
media platform
that is completely unbiased and is just
peer-to-peer rather than journalists and
doesn't rely on advertising and doesn't
isn't beholden to anybody we can just
talk to people and the idea was just
let's recreate those conversations that
we've had in restaurants and bars and
offices over the years with peers you
know you know as well as you go to
another country and meet a fellow
finance person and you will sit in a bar
and talk about all kinds of things for
hours and it won't be boring and you
have no idea where you're going to go
with it no idea what conclusions we come
to but i guarantee you'll walk away with
something in your head
thinking oh i didn't know that i need to
find out more about that or wow that's
confirmed everything i thought or that
challenges everything you know and it's
that so we just wanted to create that so
let's go and
find people who
have something to say and have some
knowledge and experience let's just talk
to them let's just sit down with them
and talk and we'll film it where other
people can be a fly on the wall for
those conversations it was a very
simplistic idea and neither of us had
any media training neither of us had any
journalism training
it was just well how difficult would it
be to do it a pub surely we can do it in
front of a camera i mean it was it was
kind of naive in many ways i guess
so that's what we started to do and and
we you know we did on a shoestring and
we did it um the four of us was the
fourth co-founder damian horner
uh who's just
one of the nicest human beings to ever
meet and it happens to be a creative
marketing genius so we had all the all
the parts there
and we just kind of figured it out as we
went along and it was kind of crazy and
a lot of fun and
you know
our first our first shoot in new york
i'll never forget this week we've
actually been
um offered
barry silbert's office um
blessing he said so you can have our
office and you can use that all day to
shoot so we lined up six or seven
interviews that day
to be shot at barry's office and we we
showed up there and his office
manchester us this is all great there's
this stuff now where's your insurance
center
and we were like
uh insurance what now
we have no idea so we're frantically
trying to how do we get insured for this
we called
the cayman islands and
tried to get insurance there but they
wouldn't give us insurance that would
cover us in new york we spoke the office
manager new york wouldn't accept cayman
alliance insurance we were screwed and
we had our first interview showing up in
like 90 minutes
and so we we ran around we rang around
and we found a hotel room
and so we repressed this hotel room for
the day we we rock up with you know
cameras and all sorts of stuff and this
room was um
it sounds grand but believe me it wasn't
it was a suite in that it had a
partition wall halfway across
that had like a little seating area and
then a bedroom
so when you walk in the door you
basically walk the petition is right in
front of you perpendicular to you and
then either side you've got the tv i
can't couch that side of the bed this
side so we took all the furniture out of
the bedroom we just piled it up on this
side of the partition board literally
it's just when you walk in it looked
like look at our warehouse we parked
this stuff up we had two chairs and a
table and a lamp and so people came in
to do these interviews and ben hunt was
one of the first people who came in that
day and um you know ben came out just
don't look right just come in and go
it'll be fine trust us it'll be fine and
so
it was just it was complete madness but
but i think if we if we'd spend any more
time
trying to understand what we
ought to do and choose that word
carefully
maybe it wouldn't happen because when
you get into what you ought to do
you suddenly find impediments everywhere
um both in terms of what people tell you
it would cost to produce a 30 minute
video we were told it'd be 25 grand to
produce a 30 minute video well well
i said we can't do that it doesn't work
so we instead of giving up we were too
late as we just had to figure it out
so um yeah it was seat of the pan stuff
and you know it i looked back on those
early pieces with tremendous pride but
you know abject horror at
mine and rails and the other guys uh
interviewing skills
um
but you know the business grew and i
think we grew along with it and it's
been it's been fantastic it's been a
whole new career i think for both of us
and um you know we were two in front of
the camera but remy and
damian the other two founders who were
very much in the background just did
just phenomenal phenomenal work with the
with the creative and with the with the
technology side of stuff
so um so
after after building this you know
what's become the netflix of finance if
if you will
uh what made you decide to leave
recently and go off on your own and
start your own podcast
okay
well the the decisions weren't um
concurrent um absolutely no it was it
was yeah we i did i did a series of
interviews in um 2018
uh called in conversation with where
where i went to uh each month i'd go to
someone's i'd invite myself into
someone's home um
and ask them if they wouldn't mind
giving me the entire day of their lives
i managed to find 12 people generous and
gracious enough to say yes
and so we i spent that year of 2018
traveling around doing those pieces
which i just i just love i i absolutely
i loved every part of those i loved the
conversations i had i loved the people i
met places i went to the creative
process in trying to
create something
that wasn't just
a conversation but that had an element
of art to it
but not for art's sake it was it was it
was trying to tell a broader story than
the conversation
and so um
i i did that year of those and i did two
pieces during that time
on the road one where i went with steve
diggle um to italy and we
went to
three cities in italy we talked about
what was happening into the time banking
crisis and politics and history and
again
just fascinating things to learn and
discover and then i had again a great
good fortune to do another one of those
in washington dc with
neil howell and harold moundran and
again it just
learned so much and were able to create
just you know really beautiful pieces
that that but even if you're not a
finance
geek like you and i
um
they're just enjoyable you know and and
you'll learn something and you learn so
but it wasn't for me it was never about
the market stuff you know i i think for
the longest time
during if you if you watch my early
interviews at real vision
you know you'll see that i was always
very much focused on
the guests and their their experiences
rather than
what they thought about
what was going to happen and and that
for me was very deliberate because i i
you know when i sat down and
rationalized it
i thought you know
i can talk to you for an hour but
but every minute we spend talking about
the future
is to
hopefully educate people guessing about
something right and it's an educated
guess and it might be based a lot of
experience but we're guessing and and
most of financial content is about the
future everyone wants to know what
should i buy what should i sell what's
the downer there what's the dollar going
to do what's it and of course
the honest answer
to that question
all the time is i don't know
because none of us do we don't know so
we're all guessing but if i talk to you
about the past if i talk to you about
your career about uh your experiences
the mistakes you've made the lessons
you've learned
you know about that so you're telling me
something that's based in knowledge and
not only is it based in knowledge but it
is something that
is
useful not just in one situation you
know what the dollar's gonna do next
week by the time you've edited this
piece and got it and released it who
knows what could happen in the two or
three days in the meantime you know the
some statement could be made some
players are cool could be put in place
and it's worthless
but you know i i i went in very early in
that year of 2018 i went to
switzerland to interview
a dear friend and a man who's become
just so important to me as a mentor and
a sounding board tony d
and um you know we sat down for a day
and and tony was just just so
wonderfully gracious with his time
and
uh
we just talked about
really just how he sees the world we
talked a little bit about his life and
his career
but really we just talked about
how he sees it and it was more a
philosophical discussion than anything
else
but it was
it was so
so profound the things he was saying you
know and tony said at one point in that
he said you know it's it's simple but
it's not easy when i asked about what
you have to do to kind of navigate this
world
and if you could boil all of this down
to one thing to me it's that it's simple
but it's not easy because it is simple
but it sure as hell isn't easy and and
that kind of
it sounds kind of trite but that little
sentence
you can take that and you can apply that
a thousand different ways in your life
um
to to
areas much broader than finance to every
area of finance and that's something
that you can live by that that's that's
words you can live by
uh i could have spent those five minutes
talking about what tony thought gold was
going to do you know and and it would
have been
interesting and it would have been a
coin toss and
it might be better than a coin toss
knows what he's talking about
but still
that
his guess about the gold price a year
hence would i wouldn't remember what
that is now um unless he'd said a
million dollars in which case i'd
remember it but for the wrong reasons so
i i kind of
i went down that road and um
you know at the time uh real vision had
kind of reached this point where
rao was was trying to scale the business
and and brown and i'd come to an
agreement that he would run the business
um because i you know i don't i don't
want
to manage a business nor do i have any
aptitude for managing it you know i'd
much rather be out
talking to people and
doing the interviews and and engaging
with the guests
so raoul was was
the ceo when i was running the business
and we've reached the point where he was
desperately trying to scale the business
and to scale the business to to bring in
a bigger audience there's a reason why
most of these outlets talk about trade
ideas and talk about
um you know what you should buy and what
you should sell because that's how you
build a big audience because people want
to be told that stuff
and so i understood why they wanted to
go that way
but for me it's just i just wasn't
interested in that i didn't want to sit
down with someone and ask them where
they thought the s p was going to be the
end of the year just it just had no
interest for me
so it just kind of came to its natural
end the brown and the business wanted to
go in this direction i just wrapped up
those um
series of interviews which were in a
completely different direction they
didn't want to go down that road anymore
which i totally respected and so it just
kind of felt like the perfect place for
me to say you know what that's great uh
you know i'm still a shareholder at that
point i still remain on the board um i
just said look i'm gonna let you guys
carry on and i'm just going back
actually just back to writing things
about your home so that was my plan i
had no plans to do a podcast i had no
plans to do anything
um but go back to my writing and kind of
figure out
what i was going to do next but um
but that
there was nothing sinister to it
everyone would love to hear some great
story of a huge bus stop it just wasn't
like that it just we reached this point
in the road where the around the
business wanted to go a certain way and
and it just didn't fit with what i
wanted to do and so you know we all
shook hands and went our separate ways
and you know and i i'm still a shelter
all the success in the world with the
business um
so that's it i mean i wish i could give
you a really juicy juicy story like you
know real housewives of cayman islands
but i got nothing for you
well what did it feel like
um you know together the four of us
built
something that we couldn't have even
dreamed that we'd be able to build and
in terms of the building of the business
you know rail takes all the credit for
that we did a fantastic job
running that and being a ceo and doing
all that stuff you know freeing damian
up to do his thing freeing remy up to do
his thing
and freeing me up to go and do my thing
i didn't know what my team was going to
be but i kind of found it through that
so you know each one of us uh
played a part in the business and i
think you know we will be bonded through
it forever i don't think you go through
something like that and and not be kind
of joined at the head forever and it was
you know it was everything you'd expect
building a business to be it was
exhilarating and frustrating and
infuriating and tiring and
wonderful everything you know it was it
was everything and i wouldn't have it
any other way i've enjoyed it from
beginning to end
um so so what did it feel like to go
back to
to the keyboard to writing
well i never really stopped you know i
i've never stopped writing things that
make you go home
through my years at real reason i kept
that up
uh it was a it was a great way for me to
just to kind of stay with my head in the
markets and stay focused on what was
going on and so i i never stopped that
and also i wasn't taking a salary for
real so i needed i needed something to
pay my rent um
so so we're going back to it again uh
with the space and time
to do it without other commitments was
was definitely
was definitely freeing it it wasn't
as hard because i was writing it in you
know in airport lounges and in hotel
rooms and you know trains and all that
all kinds of things because i had
deadlines to keep i was trapping all the
time so um it was going back and then
you know soon after that was when when
clothing hit and so
the the podcast grew out of me being
locked down in the payloads and we were
locked down here so yeah we weren't
allowed out of our homes for probably
two or three months really apart from an
hour's exercise a day and then you know
halfway through that they then banned us
from going on the beach it was it was
pretty it was pretty hardcore here
and so i was stuck at home
and um
i s i was chatting to pippa melvin on
the phone
just catching up and talking about the
world and covered and what was happening
and what have you
and i and i said to people you know this
is really fun why don't we should we
should we do this have this conversation
again or one similar to it and i'll
record it and we'll we'll kind of put it
out and let other people and this was in
the early days of zoom and everyone was
doing a you know zoom call
so i just said it would be a bit of fun
and then i thought well if i'm going to
do this
i'll
when i try and line a few more up and
i'll do them for a week so i set up this
i called a few friends and people and
just said look would you be interested
in doing these conversations with me
and so i filled up a week or ten days of
one of these conversations live every
day and i called them humanoids at the
time
and um
and just let people again say back to
that rubbish i do just eavesdrop on
conversations
and and it was so much fun you know i
really really enjoyed them because at
that time obviously we were all stuck at
home we're all desperately trying to
figure out what the hell was going on
and so to get the input of
you know of pippa and john hussman and
you know ben hunt and
diego pre and all these different people
to get their thoughts on all this it was
it was a jumble because none of us knew
was going on but it was it was such
useful information to take in and
process
and try and
figure out what was going on and so i i
did those for i think i did ten days of
them um and that and said right that's
it that was fun
i would have no plans to do any more and
i had so many emails from people saying
are you going to do any more of those
so like a month later i i lined up
another week of them i think
and again the response was great and so
i i enjoyed the conversation so it kind
of turned into a podcast really just by
pure accident it wasn't i'd love to
pretend i had this great scheme lined up
and you know this player to world
domination and i didn't i just was bored
and not talking to anybody and
i'm fortunate enough to have a lot of
really smart friends who were
still after all these years would talk
to me
so i figured well why the hell not you
know
well i mean i'm like i probably
shouldn't say this out loud but but the
one that i did with you recently was my
favorite like post covet interview
period i mean it's just it's it's well
that's because you were fantastic on it
and i'm not surprised your favorite you
were wonderful well but it's but still
it kind of feels like shooting the
breeze it's just
yeah it's fun
and and and it's just it's just a
conversation i mean the only thing the
only thing that's missing is when we're
not sitting in a pub other than that
uh exactly right which which is why i
thought what you did with art was just
beautiful do you know that bobby vans
with the two you sitting there and the
noise of the diners in the background i
absolutely love that i thought that was
just such a wonderful wonderful thing
for us to be able to sit and and listen
in on it was just it was just a delight
it really was well yeah normally we're
in studio but i have to say i'm just
gonna i'm not tooting my horn at all but
i saw that i'll say that after after
sitting down with art
at his bar stool with his plaque on his
name on his plaque in front of it in new
york it was funny the crew got there and
they were like oh no no we can't film
her and i'm like
uh he doesn't move from this spot this
is this but this look it has his name on
it this is his bar stool this is where
he sits this is where we're gonna do
this interview no matter how loud it
gets um but i did get to interview
deviselefkivich in his first long form
interview fantastic so citigroup had
finally given him clearance because it's
so hard for these sellside guys to yeah
claire i asked michael hartnett recently
because i love the flow show and he's
like nope still nope so i mean it takes
a long time to make your bones on the
sell side and actually be able to do
something like that so i i guess the
greatest honor of of my down the middle
series is that his grandkids will always
have
that that that episode that long form
episode instead of you know
snippets
that's it i think that's i think that's
a big part of it to be honest danielle i
mean that for me that was
what i wanted to do was create
a a time capsule of someone's career
that they would be proud to show their
kids and if their grandkids wanted to
know who grandpa or grandma was watch
this this will tell you everything you
need to know about
and at a time when they're still
you know
engaged and focused on a daily basis in
what made them who they are uh and that
being able to take that knowledge and
transfer it to the next generation is
just so important you know and people
people don't want to take the time to do
that you know i've i've started a new
video series recently i've just just put
the third one up i think with with pippa
and look i've spoken to pippa
she's become such a dear friend over the
last decade or so and and i have so many
conversations with pip and she's just a
remarkable woman
and we happen to be in the states at the
same time she came to my house and we
spent the day talking and you know we
ended up with a three-hour interview
people go a three-hour interview
uh wow that's that's a commitment but
hey you don't watch it you don't have to
watch it one go
but
when you dig into that and you take the
time to have these conversations
it's amazing what you what you get out
when you're not in a hurry and you don't
just want a quick answer and you know
there's so much valuable information
locked away inside experience people's
brains
but we live in a world that embraces
the the the short you know and the
kinetic and everybody wants
snappy stuff and they want it to be
bite-sized and snackable and all these
buzzwords about content
which look might be absolutely fine when
it comes to um
entertainment but i think to try and
shove finance into that bracket is
is a a big mistake i think the the the
networks that are trying to do that
and pandering to
the the audience that want short form
content ultimately i think that's going
to prove to be a a very very big mistake
um
so
the last time we were on a podcast
together i'm i'm going to shift gears
here a little bit uh because i you know
what you what you said about growing up
in a time of unrest and
in in england and obviously what we're
going through here in the united states
but
we both kind of came to the same
conclusion this is this is months ago
this is before things
became kind of as
even more divided than they are today
you you basically said politics is
economics right now and we would prefer
that that not be the case but um
but walk me through your thinking on
that uh because
it's impossible to
it's impossible to sit down in front of
bubble vision
and and look through the silo
of the financial markets and not
incorporate
the broader narrative right now
no it's look it's so true and you know
if you think about
why this is
what tends to happen is is
when you reach the end of big cycles
big economic cycles um
you find that politics becomes more
important because it's the politicians
who desperately try to keep the system
together
you know and every financial system
every reserve currency
all of these things they all ultimately
reach the end of their useful life it's
just the way the world you know we
everything about us is cyclic um
and so
when you reach these these points in
time
it's politics that allows the show to go
on longer than it should if we left
everything to purely economic forces you
and i know full well we'd have had a
major crash by now
and hey it would have been brutal but
we'd be through it uh we've found
clearing prices for assets at much more
affordable levels
and we'd be building again at the bottom
of the business cycle which is always a
great place to be and a great place for
a lot of people to make good money
but um
but you tend to see
at that point nobody wants to crash
nobody embraces the crash
so so
it comes down to politics more and more
to try and extend the cycle and and
unfortunately and nobody knows it's
better than you that that politics has
infected the marijuana reckless building
now the the fed has become politicized
it's just it's just a reality they can
say all they want
of blue about independence
face we all know that's not the case it
is now a captured political institution
and so um
you know initially the politicians kind
of abdicated the political
responsibility to the fed uh this is the
greenspan shed greenspan embraced that
and and loved being the guy right who
everybody looked to whenever things got
tough you know oh now he'll ride in and
save us and everything
people
i think the most important part of my
book and i'm not touting my book but i
think the most important takeaway is
that
in the weeks and months that followed
october 19 1987 a man who was obsessed
with the stock market was leaking
information to bond trading desks before
the fed injected liquidity in this
system through the the the open markets
desk i mean this is this is something
that he directed
yeah
it's i mean and it's funny after the
examples everywhere i remember doing a
presentation back in the
want to say 2012 maybe but i i did a
presentation and i
i had a list of names that appeared
from the bottom of the screen and i said
i want everyone in the audience i want
to want you to put your hand up when you
know
what this is a list of names of
and there are maybe a dozen names that
went up there and it wasn't until the
penultimate name
that half the hands in the room went up
and then the rest of them they had to
remember and they were the last 10 or 12
governors of the swiss national bank and
it got to simon uh peter jordan i feel
the kind of thing that that's great
and and everyone's suddenly one's hand
went up
and i said look
you weren't supposed to know these names
the fact that you now know the name of
the head of the swiss national bank is
what's important here because you should
there is no way that you should be
sitting here and know the name of the
head of the swiss national bank it's
just not supposed to be that way
um and so you know it was the same with
with the federal reserve you know until
greenspan finally we all kind of knew of
volcker because what he'd done
but try and get people to put in order
um william mcchesney martin and arthur
burns
those guys no one can do it because they
weren't that important and now we've had
greenspan and bernanke and yellen and
powell and we you know whoever's where
the power comes back
they've become household names because
they're the ones
to whom the power has been able to get
the political power to keep the cycle
going
so i think as we've reached that point
the cycles tend to end in inflation
because the nature of keeping them going
is inflationary it is essentially money
printing right that's that's that's how
you keep the game going you try to
default on all the data that's built up
through inflation
and guess what you screw it up and you
either get hyperinflation or you or you
get a deflationary impression but you
screw it up one way or the other there
isn't a soft landing on this
unfortunately
so um so i think that that
politics is is economics is it's
important to be able to understand
because the decisions that get made now
uh will continue to be politically
nature so we're trying to figure out
what's going to happen
uh
the decisions will be political in
nature until and pippa made this point
in the conversation that she and i uh
had recently
until people start writing to their
congressman and complaining about higher
prices
because that's the achilles heel it's
the achilles heel in china on a much
lower level it's the achilles steel over
here and then this is exactly what
happened with vodka people were writing
to local congressmen and you know volker
had to go to jimmy carter and say look
i'm getting pressure from everybody here
i need to i need you to go on tv
and give me the cover to raise interest
rates it's going to be painful but it's
the only way this could be done and
carter did that and then carter's out
and reagan's in and vodka as pippa said
had to go to reagan and get him to make
the exact same speech and so interest
rates have to go up to you know almost
20 percent
so um that's kind of where we are again
we're at that point the system is at its
limits the debt level is
way more now than it was back then and
the natural force of the cost of money
is higher from here
but
we may have to
have a clearing event that's much much
lower in order to get to that and i
don't know which way it'll go
they're both equally painful um the
the the feds and the government would
prefer
inflation uh rather than deflation
because it's you know it's the sneakiest
tax of all
but they're not going to get two percent
inflation which they've promised us
forever and a nice quiet glide path
they're gonna get six percent they're
gonna get you know 16 percent of europe
on the ppi industries
and it's just going to get out of hand
and that's going to require some
medicine so
you know i think everyone has to
unfortunately pay close attention to
politics now and it's it's um
it's a messy messy world
well i mean
monetary policy every time around didn't
quite do the trick we kind of slip back
down into this deflationary
disinflationary environment
but then we throw five trillion dollars
you know you direct deposited into the
accounts of americans and all of a
sudden when you that's what happens and
the fed's monetizing every dime of it
and
boom here we are and just to your point
you know the media this last
this last
fomc press conference i found to be
fascinating because they're normally
such cordial events
and the reporters
were really pressing powell saying but
people are hurting but people are
hurting so i feel like we're at this
point and now you're seeing
certain moderates come out and say
fed needs to tighten policy i mean what
was the last time you heard
a politician say that the central bank
needs to tighten policy out loud
and so um
so where do we
so you so you don't know where we're
gonna where we're gonna land i don't
either i'm just curious uh if you think
that there is at least going to be
some persistence
to the high prices that we're
experiencing in the here and now because
even if they in the lacey hunt school of
thought even if they eventually fade
it sucks right now
yeah
yeah i i i just had a
a text from it from a dear friend of
mine who was trying to
buy an iphone for one of our kids for
christmas and and she was texting me at
the apple store saying i'm in the apple
store
the only phone i can buy is the 1600
13 pro some max something
every other phone is sold out and if i
want to order one it won't be here for
christmas
um
you know and that's hashtag first of all
problems we're not we're not talking
about
you know strange food lines here but
it's amazing how insidious this is and
and i think that the big problem here
is the recent memory that people have of
covet and being unable to buy what they
want to having shelves that were empty
to to not being under by brand not being
able to buy toilet paper famously or
cleaning products or any of these things
and and when you have that
memory
in your mind
you'll pay 10 more for toilet roll if if
you know this if you have practical
experience of not being able to buy it
you'll pay 10 more for it if you can
um and you might complain
but you're not going to complain like
you would if we hadn't had what went on
in march of 2020 you got this is
absolutely ridiculous my paperless
so clomid has has
actually
jump-started this inflationary
expectation in people's minds
by giving them a frame of reference of
how it could be
and you know that's that's problematic
because you know what did my friend do
she bought the 1600 phone because it was
a christmas present for her son right
so um
that trickles down on all sorts of
levels people
will buy
the
25 steak because they promised their kid
coming home that he was going to have
steak but i'm going to have to cut back
on someone else now i promise the kids
stay the price has doubled so so these
prices going up create
problems and you know we saw this
morning announcement that this john
deere labor dispute had ended
and guess what label one
labor stuck it to capital for the first
time in a meaningful way in a long long
time
and
i think labor is now understanding
just how much capital has gotten away
with over these last 20 30 years and the
buybacks and the options and the fact
that the ceos have been making pay no
matter how tough
the the business has been and the fact
that the the working man on the assembly
line hasn't been getting paid pay rises
uh certainly not real pay increases um
and yet
we've got we've got more
multi-millionaire ceos now than any time
in history
so
that john deere thing i think is a is a
big deal julian brington spoke about in
a recent podcast i did with him and he's
absolutely right it's a big deal it
hadn't been resolved then because
the the union had basically turned down
three
actually pretty good offers from from
the company uh as to what they would
give them and they when they turned them
down it was basically look
the management have been getting rich
every year no matter what
now we want ours and so there's two
mindsets there
one is on a personal level that that
willingness to pay higher prices because
you don't want to not be able to have
that item and two is you know
someone's gonna have to pay for this and
you guys are getting rich off us and
have been for years or no more
those two
mindsets are very very dangerous for
central bankers as inflation
expectations get
entrenched because the pressure doesn't
go away for companies to increase or
expand their margins
so if you've got a double-digit ppi
and
there may be a quarter or two where
these companies
can
swallow that difference between that and
inflation but if they've got
a public that's willing to pay higher
prices believe me if they can push those
price increases through to the consumer
they absolutely will because hey
capitalism right that's what we do we're
trying to maximize our returns for our
shareholders so prices are going up 16
and we can push a 17
price like through we are going to do it
we're not going to say you know what
we've had 10 good years here guys how
about we eat some of this for the
greater good
not going to happen
so we're we're on the very very edge
here we are on the very pointy end of
potentially something
really problematic because
every single part of the world around us
every single part is now predicated upon
free money
and if you if the cost of money goes up
which everything we just spoke about
dictates it has to
then
there's a lot of things that you and i
are immersed in on a daily basis that
just don't work anymore certainly not at
the price they're at and and that's a
potentially
serious problem for
central bankers first politicians second
and
are third well especially because you
know we've got this glaring
the elephant in the room is is that
we're you know the
the first you know we're practically on
top of the first primary
for the midterm elections so
i mean a lot of nothing is is going to
happen between
between now and and
whatever january 2023 i mean it's a long
it's a long span of time for markets
when
it's obvious now the fed can't go at it
alone they have to have the fiscal
authorities
with them in order to move the needle on
consumption and the united states is a
consumption
it's a consumption led economy somebody
said a few days ago we're up to 71
of us gdp being consumption i mean it's
just a gigantic number
um
so
where is
first of all
what are your ties to singapore
and
on a broader level
is the world economy going in that
direction
is is the rise of asia and inevitability
and i'm not just talking about china at
all
well i think um it's difficult to
i struggle to think of it in terms of of
asia as a as an umbrella you know i mean
when you look at that by the way i spent
10 years in singapore and i still work
with um with my
my great friend steve diggle uh at
vulpix and you know steve is
just one of the smartest people you're
ever going to spend any time with it's
quite intimidating actually sitting and
talking to steve but um so i i've have
strong connections with singapore and uh
you know singapore has always been a
fascinating
test case for me for for an awful lot of
things you know it's it's uh
it's trite but it really is a country
run like a business and they've been
able to do that because of the
politics of the place um
and while singapore has its has its
drawbacks and you know a lot of a lot of
ink has been spilled on on the things
you can't do in singapore um
i'll say this that most of the things
you can't do
i don't want to do anyway
so uh they're pretty
there's a great bargain made in
singapore so here's the rules and you
can't do this this this this and a lot
of you might want to do these things but
you can't and if you don't do those
things
you're not going to see us the
government i'm not going to be in your
face the police aren't going to be in
your face
we're all going to get on just great but
if you do them
we're going to cane you or we're going
to put you in prison or we're going to
execute you so there's the deal and i
think it works pretty well
but because because of the the grip on
power that that um the liquid news pap
have had for the entire
length of singapore's existence as an
independent country
they've been able to to make decisions
that are
best for singapore not necessarily to
win votes because they had all the votes
and it's interesting in recent years you
you again these pressures these
inflationary pressures are starting
to happen
they're starting to be the odd decision
made
that is
clearly designed to keep certain parts
of
the the inhabitants of singapore happy
or assuage concerns they have so that
this started to reach that point where
yeah we know what's best for singapore
but
what's best for us and what's best for
singapore may not actually be the same
and coach's been injured coming's been
interesting they were
they had a three-week warranty in in
position in singapore um and no home
quarantine you've gone to singapore you
spent three weeks in a government
institution
you can't open the window i mean it was
it was as draconian as it comes
and they then put a they then put a
quarantine at home program in place for
for residents and i know this because
steve diggle was in italy waiting to try
and get back to singapore and he said
i'm not going to go until i can
quarantine at home i'll do three weeks
but it has to be at home not doing it in
a you know small room and a holiday in
um
and so they they announced that they
would put this quarantine home thing in
place
and so steve booked his flight and then
out of nowhere
the the prime minister basically
stood down his two medical chief medical
advisors
and at the stroke of penn said right
screw this we are putting in vaccine
travel lanes if you're double jabbed and
you cover certain countries there's no
question so it went from three weeks to
nothing
like that no discussion no debates in
parliament nothing
we are going to have to learn to live
with this disease so let's get on with
it let's be pragmatic and let's do this
um so that's the kind of ability
that you that you have and abilities
that
a lot of these asian countries have
um but i think when you talk about is
the world gonna
you should go that way talking about
asia to me it's really a question of
um
has
has capitalism
reached
its kind of
apogee i i don't know the answer to that
i mean i do know that capitalism as we
understand it from the earliest
explanations of it you know this is not
adam smith's capitalism right it just
isn't any more yeah
exactly right the hand is very visible
and it's slapping you around the face on
a daily basis but um
uh
what we're seeing
is is not that and so again that
suggests that we've reached the end of a
major cycle because they have they're
having to bastardize the entire system
to to make it continue to function so it
may well be that we just see uh
capitalism
we see it overthrown and we're seeing
things in the u.s now on a political
basis that i never thought i'd see in my
lifetime you know the rise of the
progressive left the the
the embrace by many people of socialism
in america
shocks me i never thought this would be
something that that would happen in
america but it's
it's not happened but it's it's much
further down that track than i ever
thought it would be and it's got more
traction than i ever thought it would
get so we're starting to see that that
people are turning away from capitalism
um because
there is an inequity to it at the moment
which which is is hurting a lot of
people and of course capitalism
doesn't allow for that if we had
capitalism we'd have bankrupt companies
littering the streets over the last 10
years
and all that dead would have been
cleaned out and people will be able to
earn income on their savings and all the
things that capitalism does
it would do but we don't have it anymore
so i don't think it's a question of
people moving towards an asian model
i think it's western democratic
capitalism
reaching a fork in the road
where you either have to return it to
what it was designed to be and what has
worked so well for centuries which
requires an awful lot of pain
or you have to
postpone the pain keep it on the road
it's going and i think at that point you
risk
veering off in a nasty left lead
direction if that's such a word i don't
know probably not
uh well it it is uh
there's a certain irony in
in chinese policymakers
talking about left-leaning policies in
the united states i mean
it twists yeah you know the truth it
twists your head into a real pretzel um
i do have one specific
years ago
the phrase capitalism with chinese
characteristics meant one thing
and today that same phrase was slightly
completely different
and that's the change i think
um over that over that 10 years but we
we still use that phrase but
you know they're still people still
going to jail in china and people are
getting executed in china and companies
are being taken down in china that's
capitalism it used to be
um
so i i have a question that's very
specific and um
and you won't have the answer i don't
have the answer
but if push comes to shove
which country do you think germany would
likely side with china or the united
states
that's a great question it's a really
really good question and i think it's an
important question well i
i'm going to throw another country in
the mix for you know
to rush
i'm in the middle of writing something
about russia and
i think i think russia is is something
that needs to be
taken seriously uh
mainly because of the guy who's running
the planes you know putin is um look you
don't rise to be a lieutenant colonel in
the kgb
without being ruthless right we know
that you don't
get stationed in east germany as a spy
without being cunning we know that
you don't retire as uh
as a lieutenant colonel kgb and be
president of your country within a
decade without
either knowing where the bodies are or
being alfred we know all this stuff
right
but
what we have now in russia
is
arguably
the only
strong leader
anywhere in the world
and i use that term
very deliberately right
with the best one in the world joe biden
is not a leader right donald trump was
not a leader he was a leader for some
but he's not a leader and a shrewd
political operator chris johnson is not
a leader scott morrison then in
australia or that fella down under his
job referred to him is not a leader
angela merkel was a leader she's gone
right
um
emmanuel macron is not a leader before
him francois hollande not a leader he
was a hunger simpson stunt tunnel but he
wasn't a leader
um so so
shooting being like or not
is a leader right now he's a leader
in a very different sense
and it's a cult of personality it's a
it's a personal autocracy that he's got
there and that's fine
but the but the leaders are not in
western democracy anymore because
to lead in the west now has become a
popularity conference
that's all it is it's
what i have to give to who to get the
enough votes to get me in power that's
it end off
um
so
i think i think that that russia which
is
a by far the biggest country on earth in
terms of land mass b has the biggest
natural resources on earth by a country
mile
c has a strong leader
uh and d has
a phenomenal position
um
physically in the world and
is now on its finger on the choke point
of energy to europe
russia has to be in this conversation
and you can't
have this conversation about what
happens next without russia and if you
look at what's happened in the west um
again i'm writing a long piece about
this at the moment which is why all this
stuff's in my head
you know every year putin sits down at
something called the valdar discussion
club and he gives his own kind of state
of the union address
and he sits there and he talks he gives
a statement and he takes questions from
the public and he does this for three
hours
three hours he sits there now we don't
get this we don't get to see this in the
west you might read
a story about it you might read the
nasty things putin said
but if you take the time to go and look
ideally watch him speak
if not listen to speak you will hear
a very
switched on
savvy politician
who is the leader of his country and
leads and farmer tonight now we know all
the things that have been said about
what he's done and i am telling you i i
don't know but i know that he is no
engine right this is a ruthless
nasty piece of work but
he's also the leader of the largest
country on the face of the earth and
we've talked for decades about wealth
what's the wealthiest country
what what's wealth
what's become wealth over the last four
years of civilization it's it's asset
prices paper money
russia isn't wealthy it's rich they've
got more oil more natural gas more coal
or gold russia is a rich country
so
i think russia needs to have
a place in this i'm not saying give them
a seat at the very top table although on
a bunch of metric because they deserve
it
but ruling them out and buying into the
narrative
that we get bombarded with in the west
that it's all about putin what an evil
person he is and how he's responsible
for trump getting elected and this and
that
every death is all down to putin you
know a lot of that stuff maybe but if
you think we're not interfering in other
people's elections i mean surely all the
snow stuff dropped those scales from
everybody's eyes about
what statecraft is all about the fact
that it's the same with every country in
the world so i i don't think this is
just about that and you ask me a
question which side's generally going to
sign on so i i've got off track there
and politics but there's stuff right
there on my head
but you are talking about
germany and and
and
and china and and contiguous borders i
mean you're talking about borders
germany with an angry russia
is in trouble
you know putin came out today and said
we need to stop the west
hijacking the climate agenda
and he's kind of right russia deserves a
seat at that table and and
india deserves a c at that table and
there are different points in their
economic development is it fair for
countries who've come so much further to
say to them you're not allowed to do
what we did to become
rich and successful
you have to do it a different way
i don't know but putin
is
a leader in in the true and
old-fashioned sense the word for good or
bad um
he's a leader and i don't see too many
of those around so i think we have to
take him
and russia very very seriously
um
we're kind of winding down here this is
something i've been wanting to ask you
for a long time uh why kiowa
well you've been you know
you know what you've been there it's
it's uh it's it's it's special it is i i
went there
in 1996 and i just
fell in love with the place i it just
there was something about it that that
you know truly speaks to me i
i've gone back i've been going over 25
years and it's it's the one place in the
world
where
you know i drive onto that island i go
past the sign that says kim island and
i'm
i'm just
peaceful you know i'm calm i'm peaceful
i
my stress levels drop and there's
something about
the combination of the nature and the
golf and the ocean and the tennis and
the cycling and
it's it's the place in the world where i
feel the most comfortable the most
relaxed the people are lovely the place
is lovely i i just
i don't i'm not hopefully not too many
people show up because it's it's still
amazingly pretty unspoiled considering
how much it's grown they've done a
fantastic job in not overbuilding and
not
kind of commercializing it beyond its
needs but it's it's just it's just a
very very special place and i would all
joking aside i would encourage everybody
to go check it out because the key was
beautiful charleston is
just a sublime city um and it's just a
very special part of the world amazing
dining too by the way you can really get
some new food in charleston
finally i i i i was i was like on the
floor i was so surprised uh i have to
ask
i don't think most people would be able
to say grant williams is a grandfather
times 2.
yes
yes yes yes yes well that's true
tell us about them
i have i have two beautiful
granddaughters uh ava who is uh who's
two and is just an absolute joy she's
just fantastic
uh and sienna who's christening it
she'll be attending uh on the 18th of
december back in the uk so i've been
back in the uk for the christian 18th
and christmas with my my daughter and my
grandkids my dad which you know after
two years of covert is is just i just
can't wait to see them all but yes i am
i have a grandfather i i i was trying to
come up with the the name that i wanted
to be called by my grandkids
and i decided that i would go with
grumpy i figured you know what grumpy's
good because
that gives me a runway right in years to
come when i'm sitting in the corner of a
chair wanting everybody to piss off i
was all grumpy i thought this is great i
can become that guy well i'm good and
ready and i'll be grumpy but of course
the best lady players of my submitted
all that so ava she can't say grumpy so
i am now bunky
unfortunately
horribly and i have become bunky which i
i kind of love a little bit more than
grumpy but yeah it wasn't it wasn't like
too much but i love it anyway well um
have you met her
yes i have i have i gone up to the uk um
last year so i've been i've been over a
couple of times i mean a lot but last
time i saw sienna my youngest
she was
she was in the blog phase you know just
say that he kind of rocker a bit but now
she's crawling and sitting up and
gurgling so it's going to be great to
get back and and see when i can actually
interact with him and just kind of
just do this with her
oh fun well grant that i wanted to end
on a super happy note and that is a
super i'm so excited that you get to go
and spend christmas in the uk actually
this episode will probably air sometime
around christmas believe it or not we're
we're
perfect we stay in the can for a while
so this will be an absolute delight
and i so appreciate you taking
a little bit of time today and and and
being on the other side being on on the
other side being the interviewee
uh and and i hope we can do this again
in a year and and you can tell me more
about more about those two gorgeous
granddaughters of yours and and but i
doubt i mean i'll be surprised but i
doubt you'll ever be grumpy i'm just
saying you're just too happy well i hope
i i hope not but listen daniel thanks
thanks everyone and uh
look with all in all honestly this is
not a comfortable position to be i i'm
not
really comfortable talking about myself
but but you you've managed to get me
doing that which is more than most
people can so uh so my thanks to you for
making it easy to talk about me for a
change which uh as i said i'm not a huge
fan enough to be honest with you
well we're huge fans of yours and i'm
not trying to blow smoke up your ass and
that's all i know
so happy christmas i think that's how
it's just to say it
absolutely right that's right i mean
this you could say it to me all day long
and the same to you and hopefully we'll
uh we'll get to see each other in person
before too long yay i'll come to kiawah
so yes absolutely take good job thanks
so much appreciate it
thanks bye bye
well if you're in my world uh your
career has grown up watching grant
williams interview
everybody everybody who we know and
that's because he's such an amazing
interviewer
so i hope that uh that like i enjoyed it
i hope you enjoyed
getting to see
who the interviewer is as a person and
what what a joy and what a happy person
and what a happy grandfather
uh so if you enjoyed it and you want to
see another kind of personal prism into
somebody
he really enjoyed that interview with
arthur cashion if you missed it for some
reason at bobby vans downtown in new
york live it was the most extraordinary
experience so if you didn't see the
arthur cashion art cashion
interview then go back and do it and
this is danielle dimartino booth thank
you once again and i will see you next
time for the next down the middle take
care
[Music]